[Musique]
Elise Lucet bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
Youtube qui s'appelle inurview on aurait
besoin de vos avis vos vos lumières
concernant le
journalisme la protection des
journalismes d'investigation je vais
essayer qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire euh sur la protection des
journalistes d'investigation la
meilleure des protections déjà c'est la
discrétion donc en général quand on fait
une investigation en l'occurrence dans
l'équipe de cach on est extrêmement
discret on en parle très très peu à
l'extérieur
donc on n'est pas parano mais il y a des
conversations qu'on a que en face à face
sans téléphone portable dans un
bureau on a parfois des ordis cryptés
parfois pas encore assez mais on est
aussi très discret par rapport tout
simplement à la profession et aux
personnes qu'on va aller interviewer qui
sont les personnes sensibles dans un
dossier c'est-à-dire que on va prendre
le dossier comme des cercles
concentriques on va commencer vraiment
l'enquête par les cercles extérieurs de
l'enquête et plus ça va aller plus on va
se rapprocher Roché du cœur nucléaire de
l'enquête mais les personnes qui sont au
cœur nucléaire de l'enquête ne vont la
prendre que très tard c'est-à-dire qu'en
général on ne les tient au courant du
fait qu'on a enquêté sur eux que dans
les toutes dernières semaines ce qui
nous permet de travailler tranquillement
pendant des mois sans qu'il ne soit au
courant la plupart du temps en tout cas
je l'espère mais ça a l'air de marcher
et et et de de n'arriver au centre
nucléaire c'est-à-dire au deux ou trois
personnes à interview et qui sont mises
en cause dans ce dossier qu'au tout
dernier moment et ça leur donne peu de
con sur notre niveau à nous de
connaissance du
dossier ils sont en général pas très
optimistes sur le savoir journalistique
il pensent que les journalistes ne
savent pas grand-chose de ce qu'il
racontent ils sont souvent surpris de
notre niveau de connaissance et quand on
arrive à faire ces interviews là avec un
tel niveau de connaissance et souvent
des documents
confidentiels qu'on a réussi à récupérer
tout au long de nos mois d'enquête
évidemment l'interview prend une tout
autre tournure au départ il Savit même
pas que moi la journaliste du 13h je
faisais ce genre d'enquête donc c'était
encore plus pratique maintenant
malheureusement en général quand il me
voit arriver ils savent un peu ce qu'il
les attendent d'accord dites-moi le
consortium de journalistes qui a sorti
les Panama papers s'apprête à ressortir
les Panama paper 2 le 9 qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire aujourd'hui
nous sommes le 4 mai al très franchement
nous on a été on est membre de l' i
c'est-à-dire que Ch investigation en
fait partie pas par hasard dans la
mesure où l'ici recrute des journalistes
d'investigation dans le monde entier en
fonction euh à la fois de leur
coopération à l' ce qui a été notre cas
puisque par le passé on a travaillé
notamment sur le lux
leak on a été au démarrage de lux leak
et donc ils se sont inspirés de tout le
travail qu'on avait pu faire sur le lux
leak pour ensuite continuer l'enquête
mais donc tous les journalistes
d'investigation de de des Panama papers
ont été recrutés comme ça nous on a
travaillé dessus pendant des mois avec
eux l'ci est extrêmement séle sur les
journalistes recrutés sauf parfois dans
des pays où c'est extrêmement compliqué
de faire du journalisme d'investigation
donc nous on s'est retrouvé dans ce
consortium qui est qui est à la tête de
la euh alors c'est un consortium qui a
été monté à Washington franchement j'en
ai oublié j'ai oublié le nom du
directeur mais c'est pas tellement
important de savoir qui qui en est le
directeur ce qui est le plus important
c'est que c'est la première fois que le
journalisme d'investigation travaille de
manière coordonnée souvent
l'investigation c'est quelque chose
d'individuel et même d' individualiste
c'est sont des gens qui travaillent dans
le plus grand secret tout seul déjà ch
est un peu une exception c'est-à-dire
que le fait que 20 journalist
d'investigation travaill ensemble MDI
part en est une autre exception mais le
plus important de l' ici c'est c'est
c'est ce côté le collectif de
journalistes d'investigation qui se met
en place dans le monde et je crois que
ça effraie beaucoup de gens parce que
tout à coup on a acquis grâce à ça une
force de frappe très importante
impressionnante mais avec des codes de
extrêmement strict c'est que chacun
d'entre nous doit respecter les codes de
l'ICIJ sur l'enquête des Panama papers
on a tous travailler pendant des mois
certains plus tardivement que d'autres
mais on a tous travaillé pendant des
mois on avait l'obligation de
n'interviewer justement le cœur
nucléaire que 3 semaines avant la sortie
mondiale on avait tous la même heure et
le même jour de sortie mondiale on avait
tous des fichiers crypté chacun avait un
code chiffré
chiffré chacun avait un code et donc euh
même à l'intérieur de cach investigation
pour vous donner un ord d'idée seul deux
personnes avaient accès réellement au
fichier depuis un terminal sécurisé oui
sécurisé comment euh franchement moi je
ne le sais pas donc c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs rassurant que que je ne le
sache pas ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que pour rentrer dans l'icici en
revanche la sécurisation des terminaux
doit être optimum et c'est une requête
très claire de l'icici euh on peut pas
être amateur de ce genre de chose quand
on a 360 journalistes dans le monde 11
médias qui travaillent sur le le même
énorme dossier euh on ne peut pas se
permettre d'être d'amateurisme c'est
c'est juste
impossible d'abord donc le le le 9 mai
on va avoir Panama paper
2 qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
moi pas grand-chose nous cache
investigation on n'ira pas sur le Panama
paper 2 c'est qu'on a on a vraiment
travaillé sur le Panama paper 1 on y a
travaillé très longtemps et comme
chacune de nos émissions fait l'objet
d'un an d'enquête on n pas pu travailler
sur le de je pense que il y a encore
beaucoup d'informations ça il y a il y a
tellement de documents à traiter que je
pense qu'on on entendra parler des
Panama papers pendant assez longtemps
nous on considère que sur la France en
ce qui nous concerne un caschee
investigation avec une nécessité d'un an
d'enquête on a fait ce qu'on avait à
faire mais ce que je ce que je pense est
vraiment intéressant dans l'icj c'est le
relais que chacun peut prendre et la
manière dont à chaque fois on sait que
chaque document va être exploité chaque
document intéressant va être exploité à
partir du moment où il est entre les
mains de cette communauté de
journalistes il sera exploité jusqu'au
bout vous avez un de vos collègues qui
est mise en examen pour les luxlix
Édouard Perrin comment ça se passe en ce
moment comment il va mieux il va
beaucoup mieux parce que en fait il est
traduit en justice avec deux lanceurs
d'alerte
euh et et l'un d'entre eux
euh jusqu'à alors éit dans une position
extrêmement compliquée euh Price
Waterhouse Coopers qui est le cabinet
d'expertise et d'optimisation fiscale
pour lequel il travaillait a tout fait
pour l'intimider le mot est extrêmement
faible et lui a fait signé une sorte de
convention qu'il avait gardé secrète
c'estàd qu'à un moment où il se trouvait
à l'hôpital on l'a appelé en lui disant
que il y avait eu un un cambriolage chez
lui il est rentré là il s'est retrouvé
face à la fois à des gendarmes et des
gens de Price water house Cooper chez
lui dans sa maison avec sa femme et
qu'on lui a dit très clairement que s'il
continuait à faire que il avait été
identifié comme l'un des lanceurs
d'alerte et que s'il continuait à faire
fiter des informations et surtout s'il
ne chargeait pas le premier lanceur
d'alerte et le journaliste en
l'occurrence Édouard Perin notre
journaliste ça allait très mal se passer
pour lui il a signé une convention
secrète et la chance a été que cette
convention secrète a été dévoilée lors
du procès et donc ce lanceur d'alerte
qui jusqu'alors chargeait plutôt notre
journaliste l'a totalement déchargé en
disant que à aucun moment Édouard ne
l'avait obligé à sortir des documents
que c'était bien lui qui avait pris
contact avec nous que nous on s'était
comporté comme tout journaliste
d'investigation doit le faire avec une
source et jamais en poussant la source à
aller chercher plus de documents en
pilotant la source de l'extérieur eu et
qu'on avait donc bien respecté les
règles de de journalisme qui sont
vraiment des règles de base vis-à-vis
d'une source et donc qu'en aucun cas on
ne pouvait avoir être accusé Édouard en
l'occurrence de complicité par rapport
au vol de documents donc je pense
qu'eddouard va beaucoup mieux depuis
cette audition qui a eu lieu vendredi
dernier euh le procès moi je je dois
l'avoir là au téléphone parce que le
procès vient de prendre fin euh il saura
quelle est la condamnation en gros
d'après ce que j'ai compris dans 3
semaines euh et on sera tous mais quand
je dis tous c'est pas à cche
investigation c'est tous les journaliste
qui s'occupe d'investigation économique
extrêmement attentif à ce qui va se
passer parce qu'on sent bien que face à
une offensive des journalistes
d'investigation qui s'appelle l'ICIJ il
y a aussi une offensive en face des
multinationales
qui est là qui est très présente qui
veut tenter d' le secret des affaires
secret des affaires ça fait partie de
d'effectivement de l'offensive qui est
mené et donc il y a le procès du
Luxembourg dont on va connaître le
résultat assez rapidement qui va être un
signal extrêmement fort et d'autre part
le secret des affaires la directive
européenne qui est passé certes en ayant
été modifié mais qui ne nous convient
toujours pas et pour laquelle
malheureusement la plupart des députés
européens Français ont voté pourquoi ça
vous convient pas parce que
euh je vais vous prendre un cas concret
en gros une entreprise qui a le
sentiment que on porte atteinte au
secret de ses affaires prenons Philippe
Maurice par exemple sur laquelle nous
avons enquêté à cache investigation à
partir du moment où moi je vais aller
voir le PDG de Philippe Maurice avec des
documents confidentiels internes de
Philippe Maurice qui révèle des
stratégies de lobbying extrêmement
fortes et à quel point ils ont pu
influencer des décisions EUR
sur les directives santé et sur les
directives tabac moi si je vais voir le
PDG de philiip mais c'est que je lui
montre ses documents ce que je fais
régulièrement parce qu'un une interview
devient encore plus évidemment pugnace
offensive intéressante si on a tous ces
documents en main et qu'on met des mois
à les accumuler si je montre au PDG de
Philippe Maurice ces documents à partir
du moment où il sait que je les ai en
main il peut décider de faire ouvrir une
une information judiciaire et et donc de
temps volé de nous poursuivre et même
d'empêcher la diffusion de l'émission
avant même qu'elle ne soit terminée
c'est une procédure billon clairement
oui complètement moi c'est une sensir
moi je dis c'est une censure qui ne dit
pas son nom et c'est donneré des armes
au aux grandes multinationales pour
tenter de tuer dans l'œuf toutes les
révélations d'investigation économique
alors ça va être à chaque fois à la
discrétion d'un juge donc bien sûr il y
aura des jurisprudences et ça va être
extrêmement intéressant de voir ce qui
va se passer justement dans les
jurisprudences à venir en France et dans
d'autres pays euh parce que je pense
qu'en France la liberté d'informer est
encore un droit souverain euh et que on
va avoir des juges qui vont plutôt aller
dans le sens des journalistes qui
révèlent ces informations mais comme on
va révéler comme on va entre guillemets
travailler sur des enquêtes qui vont
toucher des multinationales qui ont des
antennes partout il y a des pays où où
la liberté d'informer sur l'évasion
fiscale par exemple est beaucoup moins
évidente donc on pourra avoir des
procédures judiciaires qui vont être ou
en France mais aussi au Luxembourg et
dans des pays où on voit les
journalistes avec que fait que fait le
gouvernement français pour protéger ça
que fait Michel Sapin que fait François
Hollande pour l'instant le gouvernement
français on a on a eu beaucoup de
réunions avec fleur pèlerin au moment où
elle était ministre de la
Culture là depuis 2 jours je sais qu'on
va en avoir avec audreé azoulet aussi
c'est le collectif informé n'est pas un
délit qui mène cette bataille et qui la
mène plutôt bien mais il y a un peu un
double discours c'est d'un côté François
Hollande remercie très clairement le
jour des Panama papers les lanceurs
d'alertes et les journalistes
d'investigation et de l'autre on attend
toujours un soutien officiel du
gouvernement français vis-à-vis
d'Édouard Perrin qu'on a pas eu il a ils
ont pas réagi réagi 2h avant la fin du
de la dernière audition au niveau du
procès ils ont pas essayé de faire
quelque chose écoutez nous on a envoyé
une lettre ouverte à François Hollande
on attend toujours très clairement de la
part de François Hollande une prise de
position claire et que je sache regardez
caméra là et dites à la communauté des
hackurs d'aller un petit peu se pencher
sur ce dossierl alors je demande à la
communauté des hackurs de se pencher sur
ce dossier là et et et je leur dis très
franchement que la liberté d'informer
elle est extrêmement importante
euh dans ce genre de dossier économique
si on ne bouge pas si on ne se si on ne
se mobilise pas tous les multinationales
vont une fois de plus gagner parce
qu'elles ont énormément de moyens bien
sûr et donc des batteries d'avocats et
elles vont tenter de d'influencer les
les les toutes les procédures
judiciaires qui vont avoir lieu ça va
être crucial ce qui va se passer dans
les semaines ou dans les mois à venir
donc c'est maintenant qu'il faut se
mobiliser c'est maintenant qu'il faut
bouger et c'est maintenant que le
gouvernement français doit prendre
position vis-à-vis des lanceurs
d'alertes je dirait que c'est quand même
il y a eu des efforts de fait dans la
loi sain 2 notamment pour que les
lanceurs d'alerte la pour que les
lanceurs d'alerte pardon est un vrai
statut c'est inimaginable mais quand je
dis inimaginable de penser que Hervé
Falciani Stéphanie
gibaau se retrouve Antoine Deltour se
retrouveve en ayant pris des risques
considérables pour au moins Stéphanie
gibaau sans travail depuis 5 ans au RSA
menacé d'advirer de son appartement
parce qu'elle a plus les moyens de payer
son loyer et que le gouvernement
français à qui elle a permis sûrement à
terme elle va permettre de récupérer 12
milliards d'euros puisque c'est Michel
Sapin lui-même qui dit que priori toute
l'affaire UBS va permettre à la France
de récupérer 12 milliards d'euros ne
bouge pas le petit doigt pour aider
Stéphanie gibbaau donc ils ont peur de
quoi c'est ils ont peur de motiver ils
ont peur de motiver d'autres lanceurs
d'Alert ils ont peur de quoi ça un ça
n'était pas dans les textes et je pense
que il faut que les texte de loi évolue
plus vite par rapport à la société la
société change la société bouge et il
faut que que les lois évoluent plus vite
ça c'est la première chose de vous
imaginez très bien que face à des
lanceurs d'alertte comme cela les
grandes sociétés
bougeent énormément et font un lobbying
de folie vis-à-vis des différents
gouvernements pour qu'il n'y ait aucun
statut de protection des lanceurs
d'alertes pour eux c'est un danger
extrême si quelqu'un de l'intérieur fait
sortir des documents qui sont des
documents cruciaux qui montrre à un
moment que ces entreprises se sont joué
des lois où on fait de l'évasion ou de
l'optimisation fiscale à outrance c'est
c'est un danger absolu donc il y a eu un
mouvement extrêmement fort et puissant
de lobbying de ces multinationales qui
ont tout fait pour que les lanceurs
d'alertes ne soient pas reconnus c'est
mieux dans la loi Sapin 2 mais ça n'est
pas encore suffisant et je tiens à dire
franchement que pour nous journalistes
c'est déterminant c'est-à-dire que la
protection des lanceurs d'alerte c'est
la protection des gens qui à un moment
dans une entreprise constate des
infractions graves et plutôt que de se
glisser dans le courant et dans la
tièdeur de leur travail et de se dire
surtout j'ai rien vu j'ai rien vu j'ai
rien entendu je diraiis rien Ste dur
rang prennent des risques immenses nous
parlent nous confient ces documents et
et en retrouve vraiment se retrouve avec
une vie brisée derrière donc nous on se
doit en tant que journaliste de protéger
aussi ces gens ça c'est la protection
des sources un maximum mais en revanche
quand ils sont mis au jour quand ils
sont découverts de les aider le plus
possible parce que c'est grâce à eux
souvent que les plus grands scandales
arrivent jusqu'aux téléspectateurs
jusqu'aux auditeurs jusqu'aux lecteurs
jusqu'au aux gens qui regardent vos
chaînes donc c'est c'est déterminant de
protéger ces gens ils sont trop seul
vous vous avez pratiquement un quart de
siècle dans la maison du journalisme
vous venez de de de quitter le journal
de 13h pour vous occuper ou du moins
reprendre à peu près la moitié de France
Télévision au niveau de l'investigation
non vous avez repris quoi là comme
émission envoyé spécial complément
d'enquête et je garde cash bien sûr
voilà donc ça fait à peu près la moitié
de France Télévision ça fait du boulot
euh pourquoi vous êtes pas trop
intéressé à l'époque à l'affaire clear
stream et deny Robert parce que à
l'époque j'avais pas une émission
d'investigation en ordre de marche aussi
forte que celle d'aujourd'hui euh parce
que je pense que j'étais un peu jeune
aussi parce que j'en ai pas forcément
compris tous les enjeux à ce moment-là
euh parce que Denis était aussi un
personnage pas toujours évident à cerné
en tout cas pour la jeune journaliste
que j'étais puis qui s'est pas forcément
non plus tourné vers moi à
l'époque et que je pense franchement que
Denis Robert a été le précurseur dans ce
journalisme là et ces lanceurs d'alerte
ont été les précurseurs c'est que
aujourd'hui quand on voit les Panama
papers quand on entend Stéphanie gibau
quand on entend Antoine Deltour on a
l'impression de revivre plus de 10 ans
après les les les mêmes événements et et
de comprendre à quel
point cette ampleur elle est enfin je
veux dire ce genre de pratique a une
ampleur mondiale que c'est partout que
ces gens sont persuidés qu' sont
extrêmement tranquilles et que de temps
en temps il y a un Denis Robert qui est
un un petit grain de sable qui qui vient
mettre un peu de bazar dans leurs
affaires mais bon pas trop parce que on
arrive à le déstabiliser Denis a eu je
enfinè voilà c'est pas je crois c'est je
sais a été harcelé judiciairement
parlant découragé je crois aussi
professionnellement
parlant et que je crois que la meilleure
réponse d'ailleurs ça me fait plaisir
d'entendre à nouveau Denis Robert parler
aujourd'hui c'est que la meilleure
réponse qu'on fasse à au cas Denis
Robert d'il y a plus de 10 ans c'est la
l' icij c'est-à-dire de dire à un moment
tout ça est trop lourd pour un
journaliste tout seul personne n'est
assez costaud pour subir tout ça et que
la communauté des journalistes si elle
est assez maline et intelligente pour se
rassembler et faire groupe face à ça là
ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué alors
on a beaucoup reproché à l'ciij d'être
financé par sorus et d'être un AAD de la
politique étrangère américaine qu'est-ce
que vous avez à répondre à ça écoutez
moi j'en ai pas le sentiment pour avoir
vu un peu la manière dont dont ça
fonctionne après je pense que si il y a
une dérive ou s'il y a un pilotage de
l'ICI les journalistes d'investigation
qui en font partie maintenant sont
suffisamment indépendants les uns des
autres justement pour aller voir y
compris dans le fonctionnement de l' ici
s'il y a des choses qui ne vont pas euh
pour l'instant
moi j'ai le sentiment mais même c'est
plus qu'un sentiment j'ai la certitude
que l'ICIJ apporte beaucoup plus de
choses positives que de questions
importantes c'està-dire que est-ce que
oui ou non il faut se poser des
questions sur pourquoi il y a peu de
révélation sur les États-Unis dans les
Panama papers oui bien sûr qu'il faut se
poser la question est-ce qu'il faut pour
autant remettre en question tout ce que
les Panama papers ont permis de
découvrir partout dans le monde non
c'estàd que dans la balance pour
l'instant moi je regarde le côté positif
de l'ICIJ je pense à Denis Robert je me
dis qu'on fait beaucoup de chemin que
évidemment tout ça n'est pas pas
statique et qu'il faut pas on n pas trop
le genre à s'auto féliciter les uns les
autres à s'auto conratuler mais qu'en
revanche on est en train de de de de
monter quelque chose de fabriquer
quelque chose qui en plus sera sous les
yeux de tous les journalistes
d'investigation du monde entier donc ça
va être compliqué d'en faire quelque
chose de de de vicier euh et et que je
pense en revanche qu'on va pouvoir
apporter énormément de choses je crois
qu'il y a des gens qui se qui qui
commence à se dire waouh ils sont
beaucoup ils sont nombreux ils sont
organisés ils travaill longtemps ils
savent garder un secret et quand ça
quand l'information sort ça fait boou
donc je pense qu'il y a quelques
personnes qui doivent se dire en ce
moment ou quelques groupes qui doivent
se dire en ce moment on est un peu moins
tranquille on va engager des tueurs
c'est ça non non parce qu'il faudrait
tuer beaucoup de monde justement c'est
ça par rapport à Denis Robert c'est
Denis il a pas été tué physiquement mais
il a été tué autrement non il est
toujours vivant on l'a reçu il y a 4 ans
il y a 3 an c'est professionnellementé
plus il a pas longtemps é branlé et et
et même remis en cause dans la
profession mais il a été remis en cause
dans la profession par qui oh par
beaucoup de gens mais nous aussi à cach
on a été remis en cause dans la
profession Mia partle aussi euh ceux qui
font leur boulot en fait oui mais si
vous voulez il y a moi j'aime pas du
tout être donneuse de leçon donc chacun
fait le métier comme il l'entend euh on
va dire que on n pas tous les mêmes
manières d'exercer notre profession
euh et et et que le fait qu'en France un
certain journalisme d'investigation
refasse son
apparition et et pour le coup qu'on soit
assez soudé souder les uns avec les
autres en a dérangé plus d'un ça devient
compliqué maintenant de nous contester
mais je je j'entends encore toutes les
critiques faites notamment vis-à-vis de
Fabrice harfy de méia part sur l'affaire
kusac c'est quand même énorme le
Jean-Michel Apathie qui lui réclame ses
sources en direct c'est j'ai trouvé ça
extraordinaire et benoî Bringer qui a
travaillé pour nous pour pour les Panama
papers s'est fait le plaisir quand il a
été interviewé par Jean-Michel apatti il
y a pas il y a pas si longtemps que ça
au moment de la sortie des Panama papers
de lui approu de lui apporter la preuve
du compte caché de Cahusac au Panama
donc là il l'avait sous les yeux il
était un peu embêté mais si vous voulez
il y a il y a plusieurs manières
d'exercer le journalisme moi encore une
fois je suis pas donneuse de leçon mais
je je pense simplement que c'est
compliqué
euh de critiquer des gens qui
travaillent longtemps sérieusement en
collectif alors vous avez travillé vous
avez travaillé sur des millions et des
millions de docs leur proche qui a été
fait dans la communauté du ha et par
l'intermédiaire de Julian Assange c'est
full full discloser c'est pourquoi nous
on peut pas Diguer c'est
creuser dans les Panama papers je sais
pas pour l'instant il y a une vraie
réflexion là-dessus c'est àir
c'est-àdire est-ce que est-ce que oui ou
non il y a une mise à disposition de de
tout ce qu'on a d'abord il y a une
première question qu'on doit se poser
c'est si la mise à disposition de tout
ce qu'on a met en danger la source ça
c'est la première chose donc si à si
mais ne serait-ce qu'une seule seconde
la source est en danger parce que
justement en révélant tout ce qu'on a
tout à coup on peut se dire mais d'où ça
vient et on peut remonter à une personne
alors il ne faut pas le faire s'il y a
la mise en danger d'une source c'est
même pas en r vous faites pas comme dans
les services de renseignement vous
sacrifiez pas votre source quoi vous
l'instrumentalisez pas non d'accord
c'est pas possible on peut pas faire ça
ah vous avez un cœur et une éthique
c'est ça oui et puis c'est c'est un
engagement collectif qu'on a pris tous
vis-à-vis enfin c'est un engagement
professionnel c'est ça fait partie des
du B àas du du journaliste
d'investigation mais en plus c'est un
engagement collectif qu'on a pris quand
on rentre dans dans la communauté de l'
iciij on prend cet engagement donc déjà
révéler la totalité des documents qu'on
a peut être une information pour
remonter jusqu'à la source si c'est le
cas c'est no way après le débat sur la
mise à
disposition de de tous les documents
nous on l'a eu sur sur plusieurs sur
plusieurs enquêtes et on est encore
hésitant à cach sur le fait de de quand
on a en main des documents qui ne sont
qu'entre nos mains et et de quelques-uns
qui nous les ont fournis en marche de la
mise en danger des sources là c'est ça
se discute même pas si s'il y a mise en
danger d'une source on oublie mais après
si on a un vrai doute
sur ce côté bien sûr qu'on le met en
main de la communauté des haurs mais pas
seulement on va le mettre tout le monde
va avoir accès à ça les multinationales
aussi elles vont peut-être savoir et
comprendre comment on travaille elles
vont peut-être décrypter des modes de
fonctionnement qui nous sont propres et
on en a pas très envie donc on est en
débat je dis pas que notre décision pour
l'instant elle est définitive et que on
donnera pas à un moment sur des dossiers
précis ou ou même plus globalement des
dossiers à la communauté des hackurs ou
à d'autres au grand public mais on est
encore en débat là-dessus et c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on tranche en 3
secondes juste parce qu'on en a envie
c'est c'est pas ça je pense qu'il faut
qu'on prenne une décision réfléchie
parce qu'elle va être elle sera
importante et qu'on sache exactement en
ayant pesé le pour et le contre pourquoi
on fait ça mais sur la démocratisation
de de l'information et y compris des
informations sensibles euh moi je sais
que en tout cas nous le fait que on
réussisse à décrocher une émission de
prime time dans une chaîne qui s'appelle
France 2 qui est qui est la premium de
France Télévision et où on met ce genre
de d'émission en prime est déjà un
premier pas important parce que
on a réussi à prouver qu'entre nous et
les téléspectateurs il y avait un vrai
lien c'est-à-dire une volonté de savoir
et que elle est beaucoup plus importante
si vous voulez quand l'émission sur les
Panama papers fait 17 % de part de
marché c'estàdire 3 million et demi de
personnes et qu'en face sur TF1 il y a
une émission consacré au visiteurs et
qu'on les plie bien sûr que c'est une
satisfaction personnelle mais pas que
c'est quand même ça dit quelque chose de
la société d'aujourd'hui et de la
volonté de savoir un appétit et de
savoir ce qu'on cache c'està-dire savoir
ce qu'on dissimule et de de bien voir
que maintenant tout le monde a compris
qu'il y avait de très belles opérations
de communication qui étaient destiné au
grand public mais que le grand public il
est plus prêt à juste prendre les
opérations de communication et à faire
semblant de croire qu'il y a rien
derrière pourquoi à votre avis parce que
le grand public il est grand et que faut
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles il y a de multiples manières
de s'informer et ça ça a été une vraie
chance dans notre
profession le média unique c'est c'est
pas que c'est fini mais c'est mort et
enterré et tant mieux donc il y a
beaucoup de gens qui cherchent partout
qui ont des profils différents qui ont
pas forcément une carte de presse mais
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont une carte de
presse qui cherchent pas bien il y a
beaucoup de gens qui nous informment
différemment après il faut faire le tri
vraiment entre le bon grain et livré on
est bien d'accord il y a du boulot parce
que sur internet il y a il y a de tout
et de rien sur les sites il y a de tout
et de rien mais cette
multiplication on va dire des des
curieux potentiels ou des journalistes
potentiels moi je trou trouve à donner
d'abord un coup de booster à la
profession nous fait qu'on a des relais
d'information dans dans beaucoup
d'endroits alors qu'on les avait pas ou
difficilement et en tout cas pas aussi
rapidement et puis je trouve que c'est
assez formidable parce que ça veut dire
que euh les les les les téléspectateurs
sont des citoyens ils ont envie de
savoir ils ont envie d'agir parfois et
que parfois on se dit que derrière la
télé il y a les lanceurs d'alertes
potentieles de demain et donc qui sont
dans une société aujourd'hui une
multinationale et qui en regardant des
émissions comme la nôtre se disent
est-ce que je continue à rester
silencieux ou pas est-ce que vous
craignez pour votre sécurité
non non c'est pas enfin non très
franchement non d'abord parce que je
suis pas journaliste
pigiste je suis Élise Lucé mais je suis
Élise Lucet de France Télévision donc
s'attaquer à moi c'est quand même
s'attaquer à un groupe puissant non
c'est une cible de
choix oui c'est peut-être une cible de
choix mais je je je pense être protégé
aussi par par France Télévision et par
le groupe et je pense que si quelqu'un
voulait s'attaquer à moi entre
guillemets pour faire un
exemple d'abord ça susciterait
exactement le la réaction inverse
c'est-à-dire que il y aurait je sais pas
combien de confrères à reprendre toutes
les enquêtes que que je ou nous
n'aurions pas pu finir donc je pense que
ce serait complètement vain on n'arrête
pas un mouvement comme celui-ci et et
c'est pas en s'attaquant à une personne
comme moi qu'on qu'on arrête ça encore
une fois peut-être à l'époque de Denis
Robert en en étouffant Denis sous les
procès on pouvait penser arrêter une
forme de journalisme d'investigation
mais aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui ferait ça
c'est quelqu'un qui voit pas le monde
c'est quelqu'un qui comprend pas le
monde d'aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui
vit encore au 20e alors qu'on est au 21e
et que le 21e va très vite qu' en a
beaucoup des gens comme ça nond qu' en a
beaucoup des gens comme ça oui c'est
possible très placé non non non mais
c'est c'est possible mais ce serait une
erreur ça ne servirait à rien donc je
les décourage d' avance ça serviserait
strictement ce serait contreproductif
ris le risque terroriste en étant
journaliste femme reprenant euh
des investigations du moins des
magazines d'investigation qui peuvent
potentiellement euh traiter ce genre de
problème moi je peux vous dire que je
vais plus dans certains pays où j'allais
parce que parce que parce qu'il faut je
je suis pas parano mais il faut être un
temps soit peu prudent sur ce qu'on
représente et j'ai beau vouloir m'en
détacher et dire et je pense me
comporter comme une personne normale il
y a un moment où comme vous le dites
fort bien on devient une cible malgré
soi donc j'en suis une malgré moi donc
il y a des pays où je ne vais plus parce
que les pays lesquels bah j'allais
beaucoup en Mauritanie à un moment parce
que j'y ai des des attaches fortes et
que avec le désert notamment et avec les
gens du désert et où j j'y ai fondé une
association pour sauver des des
manuscrits anciens et donc j'y suis
allée je sais pas une vingtaine de fois
évidemment je n'y vais plus surtout
surtout dans les oasis du désert là pour
le coup c'est c'est même pas la peine
mais je vais plus au Maroc je vais plus
en Égypte je vais plus dans tous ces
pays je voilà je je je pense qu'à un
moment il faut il faut avoir
l'intelligence de comprendre que le
monde change y compris pour soi et que
et qu'on représente une cible malgré soi
vous iriez en Arabie Saoudite non je
pense
pas notre communauté nous a demandé de
vous poser une question concernant un
très vieux documentaire documentaire une
très vieille émission concernant la
pédophilie oui c'est loin oui bon vous
avez pas beaucoup changé hein c'est
gentil mais si si si pourquoi le sujet
n'est plus abordé comme vous l'avez fait
à l'époque maintenant dans les médias je
pense qu'il le sera à nouveau moi je je
pense que
euh je je pense que l'affaire Barbarin
en soit est en train de de de réveiller
des vieux démons et je pense que c'est
nécessaire euh je pense que ça y est
j'ai un trou de mémoire le film qui a
reçu l'Oscar aux États-Unis sur
Spotlight SP je je pense que Spotlight
est vraiment l'exemple de ce que peut
être le journalisme d'investigation moi
c'est un film que j'ai adoré et c'est
l'exemple de ce que peut être le
journalisme d'investigation euh alors
c'est c'est du Data à la papa hein parce
que quand on voit Spotlight il recherche
dans des vieux registres des archives et
cetera mais mais je pense qu'il a il y a
du travail à faire dans ce domaine et je
pense franchement qu'il faut que le
journalisme d'investigation soit se
repenche sur ce genre de sujet qu'il a
des choses à faire et que quand on voit
euh ce qui se passe dans le diocèse de
Lyon ce qui s'y est passé et ce qui s'y
passe aujourd'hui on se dit que il y a
il y a il y a vraiment matière à une
enquête extrêmement fouillée je pense
qu'il faut pas viser d'ailleurs
seulement le clerger c'est clair il faut
il faut faut pas être monomaniaque il y
a il y a pas que le clergé hein non il y
a pas que le clergé et puis il y a eu un
problème moi ce qui m'intéresse le plus
là-dedans c'est le problème des
institutions quelle qu'elles soi qu'ell
soit religieuse ou politique et c'est
comment à un moment où oui ou non et
c'est à cette question qu'il faut
répondre des institutions ont pu couvrir
organis organiser point d'interrogation
mais en tout cas couvrir et et on va
dire dans les grandes mesures ou pas des
actes qui sont totalement répréhensibles
et juste insupportable et inacceptable
et si c'est le cas je dire que si on se
lance là-dessus si on travaille dessus
je pense qu'on trouvera des choses on
m'a nous a fairemonté aussi d'autres
questions concernant les 28 Pag à 750
milliards ça vous
parle 28 pages concernant le rapport du
11 septembre
euh qui doivent ou qui devrai être
disclogure sorti
et vouvez pas non non non je me trompe
voulaz pas parler de la mort de Ben
Laden et de ce qui a sorti derni ce qu'
sorti des services secrets américains
là-dessus non pas encore on vient on y
arrive donc 28 pages d'un rapport
incriminant l'Arabie Saoudite l'Arabie
Saoudite tu as menacé de liquider 750
milliards d'actifs aux États-Unis si
Barack Obama permettait la divulgation
des 28 pages ah bah pardonnez-moi
j'étais pas au courant j'aurais dû eu
clair c'est une faute professionnelle
mademoiselle c'est tout à fait je la
reconnais donc je vous l'explique en
simple voilà
euh pourquoi le 11 septembre alors nous
nous on on a travaillé autour du 11
septembre concernant la finance et la
l'aspect économétrique du 11 septembre
autour des délis d'initiés et des put
option qui avait av été mis euh euh sur
American airlin United airlin on s'est
on a beaucoup creusé il y a un
professeur en Suisse qui s'appelle Marc
chînet de l'Université de zurc euh qui
s'est un petit peu penché sur le sujet
et qui a été discrédité d'un coup comme
un journaliste qui mettait les doigs où
il fallait pas
euh pourquoi le 11 septembre est un
sujet tabou chez les journalistes ah ça
allit pas çait pas alors écoutez de nous
très franchement moi je me souviens
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire sur
les délis d'initiés autour du 11
septembre mais parce que parce que
franchement on a pas travaillé dessus
mais pour moi c'est pas du tout tabou
alors pas du tout du tout du tout et
pour vous dire que c'est pas tabou c'est
que moi je me souviens très très bien
vous allez me dire que c'est ancien et
c'est pas en sortant de vieilles
émissions qu'on se justifie mais ça
montre que pour moi il y a zéro tabou
sur le 11 septembre mais zéro alors
franchement zéro
euh quand quand il y a eu le 11
septembre on a extrêmement rapidement
nous travailler en ayant d'ailleurs des
documents hyper intéressants enfin moi
je j'avoue que j'ai appris énormément de
choses à ce moment-là et et on on se
débride les yeux là c'est c'est c'est
que d'un côté on voyait le 11 septembre
qui venait de se produire et de l'autre
on était capable de comprendre comment
les États-Unis la France pour lutter
contre les Russes qui avaient pris
l'Afghanistan avait fourni des des armes
et avait formé des gens qui ensuite ces
mêmes armes se sont retourné contre les
Américains et les mêmes gens qui ont
étaié formés se sont retrouvés avec Ben
Laden pour pour faire les attentats du
11 septembre et c'était un décryptage du
11 septembre qu'on a fait très peu de
temps après nous on avait fait ça dans
pièce à conviction je crois que c'était
2 mois
après et pour le coup si vous
voulez là sur les implications
financières à mon avis il y a
effectivement à creuser c'est pas du
tout un sujet tabou c'est c'est très
intéressant et non non là le 11
septembre pour moi n'est absolument pas
un sujet tabou alors ça fait plaisir
entendre parce que nous on s'est amusé à
regarder comment les journalistes
français avaient traité les 28
pages à 750 milliards et je vous
conseille d'aller voir simplement
faire une capture d'écran de ce qui est
sorti concernant ces 28 dans la presse
française serit atterré c'est-à-dire il
y a TR qu peut-être C articles qui se
battent en duel quoi oui après et puis
et puis et puis même allez je vais dire
7 7 7 il y a médiap qui s'est pchéus
mais après j'espère qu'on se parle
franchement oui non mais on on va se
parler franchement où je vais pas être
très sympathique pour ma profession et
je me mets
dedans on change d'obsession c'est que
l'obsession française c'est daesh et
c'est pas que l'obsession française mais
vu les attentats qui viennent de se
produire en France euh il y a il y a
cette obsession sur daesh et vous allez
pouvoir
voir énormément de papiers démissions
sur daesh des angles très différents et
et et parfois on a la mémoire courte
c'est-à-dire que le temps journalistique
n'est pas
forcément le temps d'une vraie bonne
enquête qui peut durer parfois 25 ans
donc le temps journalistique est très
court nous on se bat pour que le temps
journalistique se rallonge chaque
enquête de cche c'est un an en France ça
n'existe existait pas une enquête d'un
an à la télé ça n'existait pas ou très
peu donc on on se bat pour rallonger ce
temps-là mais c'est vrai qu'il faut être
honnête et se dire se regarder bien
droit en face dans le miroir et se dire
que oui on a tous à un moment un
tropisme sur un sujet et en ce moment le
tropisme c'est le groupe état islamique
et et quitte à en oublier d'autres
choses qui sont toutes aussi importantes
donc moi je dirais plutôt ça euh je suis
pas sûr qu'il a la volonté de absolument
ne pas en parler c'est juste que à un
moment tout le monde journalistique
français est obsédé par ça et tente
d'avoir des informations là-dessus et
pense que le 11 septembre c'est loin
c'était il y a longtemps euh c'était
hier pourtant sans le 11 septembre il y
aurait peut-être pas eu l'émergence
d'autant de terrorisme on est d'accord
mais dans le temps journalistique c'est
loin c'est 15 ans c'est loin et et c'est
un tort c'est-à-dire que moi je suis
pour qu'on revienne sur le 11 septembre
je suis pour qu'on revienne sur laaffire
Boulin je suis pour qu'on revienne sur
la pédophilie on y retravaille en
regardant ce qui s'est passé entre dans
les années 60 à 90 je suis pour tout ça
simplement c'est beaucoup de travail à
chaque fois et
euh ce que j'espère moi c'est susciter
beaucoup de vocation et s'imer oui parce
que il faut qu'on soit beaucoup il faut
qu'on soit beaucoup il y a il y a il y a
une nécessité vraiment forte euh de
d'avoir euh de de de retrouver une
communauté de journalistes
d'investigation forte en France à un
moment elle a failli disparaître euh
quel moment moi je dirais euh 70 80 il y
avait quasiment plus rien quand on a a
créé pièce à conviction euh je crois
qu'il y avait on était deux magazines
d'investigation à se battre en duel
maintenant il y en a beaucoup plus et
euh et puis et puis maintenant il y a
plein de manières d'investiguer
différentes c'est vous en faites partie
j'en fais partie il y a une communauté
d'investigateur beaucoup plus large
beaucoup plus importante etê à
journalisme 2.0 c'est çaoui bien sûr on
on peut on peut se nourrir les uns les
autres on peut c'aider les uns les
autres sans guitare à la main et sans
chanter autour d'un feu de bois mais
pour de vrai et donc mais j'espère
susciter des voocations pas que moi mais
quand les gens regardent cach ils voient
aussi mes enquêteurs qui sont à l'image
et qu'on voit beaucoup et leur
implication sur le terrain il faut
comprendre que ils passent à chaque fois
un an de leur vie dans une enquête et
quand je dis dans une enquête c'est dans
une enquête c'est ils sont obsédés par
leur enquête pendant un an ils
travaillent comme comme des dingues et
ça j'espère que ça sucite des des
vocations ce qui me fait extrêmement
plaisir c'est ce que les on me renvoie
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
jeunes journalistes qui m'appellent en
me disant moi Madame quand je serai
grand c'est ce ce journalisme là que je
veux faire donc ça c'est assez
formidable et que quand je suis dans la
rue les gens qui m'arrêtent et il y en a
beaucoup m'arrête en me disant continuez
surtout et si vous arrivez la moindre
chose on vous soutient on est là surtout
ne lâchez rien et ça ça veut dire que on
globalement on répond à une demande
forte du public et que donc si à
l'avenir quelqu'un voulait museler cette
presse là d'investigation ça va être
compliqué ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué que que qu'auparavant alors le
on entend bien le fait que les gens vous
adulent parce que c'est normal qu adulé
hein au contraire il me renvoie pas du
tout euh c'est pas du fan c'est c'est un
respect par rapport à votre votre
travail ouais et puis ils sont un peu
genre Contin continu on vous soutient
euh c'est il me donne de l'énergie il me
donne des forces mais pas que pour moi
pour toute mon équipe et et c'est euh
c'est genre vous faites partie des gens
nécessaires ou vous faites votre équipe
fait partie des choses nécessaires dans
dans dans une démocratie d'aujourd'hui
pas que moi méia part d'autres d'autres
émissions d'investigation mais des gens
qui se battent aujourd'hui pour que la
vérité émerge face à un système de
communication qui a pris un pouvoir
fou là les gens le disent clairement ils
réclament ça ils sont pas dupes de ce
système de communication politique
économique marketing qui s'est mis en
place ils ont le sentiment d'en être
souvent les dindons de la farce et ils
en ont marre vous comprenez cette
défiance alors oui parce que oui oui oui
oui oui je veux dire on peut tout vendre
comme un produit mais à un moment il
faut faut arrêter de prendre les les
gens qui sont en face pour des imbéciles
la politique n'est pas un produit moi je
je suis désolé après qu'une
multinationale a des produits à vendre
bien sûr ok ça je l'entends je le
comprends c'est son job qui fasse de
l'argent bien sûr ça je l'entends je le
comprends je suis pas dans un truc ultra
gauche en disant les entreprises ne
doivent pas faire de Bénéfic c'est pas
ça c'est après c'est c'est juste qu'il y
a des lois des règles et que c'est pas
parce que c'est une multinational
qu'elles doivent pas respecter des lois
et des règles nous on nous dit souvent
oui vous êtes anticapitaliste vous
détestez les entreprises non on déteste
pas les entreprise la vie est pas noire
blanche on déteste pas les entreprises
on déteste pas les multinationales c'est
jqu'à un moment o on dit que leur statut
multinational ne fait pas qu'elles
peuvent s'affranchir des lois c'est tout
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
détestez moi j'ai pas de j'aime j'aime
pas he je like pas les choses j'aime la
vérité voilà c'est tout j'aime la vérité
et je vais la chercher parfois la ça
dérange mais il y a pas de j'aime pas
les chefs d'entreprise ou j'aime pas les
les gens deci ou les gens de là c'est à
un moment on a des document précis sur
une entreprise la manière dont elle
s'est affranchi des lois on travaille
sur ces documents on le fait
sérieusement on va au bout des choses et
si à un moment un attaché de presse un
chargé de communication de crise ou pas
nous dit non vous ne pourrez pas
interviewer monsieur machin et ben on va
tout faire pour l'interviewer quand même
euh il y a un S tank de journaliste qui
s'est créé récemment on a interviewé euh
ça sa présidente récemment Natacha
Polonie oui ça s'appelle le comité
Orwell ou euh il lutte contre ce qu'il
décrivent comme la police de la pensée
qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez je sais pas ce qu'elle elle voit
elle Natacha dans la police de la pensée
c'est-à-dire la pensée unique le fait
que à un moment des si elle est dans le
journalisme d'opinion moi j'y suis pas
mais dans le journalisme d'opinion que
toutes les opinions a le droit de
s'exprimer oui enfin moi je ok moi je
suis pas du tout dans le journalisme
d'opinion je suis vraiment dans du pur
journalisme de de la on cherche la
vérité on vérifie on trace on creuse des
sillons on voit on cherche des preuves
on veut des preuves et si on n' pas de
preuves on avance pas donc on fait
peut-être voilà moi je suis le
journalisme d'opinion c'est vraiment un
métier particulier j'en fais pas partie
j'ai aucune envie d'en faire partie je
les méprise pas du tout on en a besoin
euh et c'est très bien d'ailleurs qu'il
y a des gens comme ça mais c'est très
bien euh aussi qu'on dise al tuas la
pensée unique j'ai un peu l'impression
d'avoir entendu cette chanson là déjà il
y a il y a 10 ou 15 ans ou 20 ans et on
l'entend régulièrement mais je pense que
c'est bien à des moments que que des
journalistes par exemple des
journalistes qui suivent la politique
puissent dire ça parce que c'est vrai
que on commence à sentir que même dans
le traitement de la politique il y a des
changements il y a enfin des changements
à quel
niveau c'est tout simple mais nous on
l'a fait mais mais mais je comprends pas
que que que enfin c'est de plus en plus
fait maintenant dans les JT ou ailleurs
mais quand est-ce que vous trouvez
normal qu'on qu'on emmène des
journalistes dans des voyages officiel
en charter et que et que jamais les
journalistes nai filmé les conditions
dans lesquelles ces voyages officiels se
déroulent et quand quand Natacha ça
maintenant je je donne pas de leçon
parce que maintenant on commence à voir
les quand Natacha Polonie pose la
question à christineocrent sur les
réseaux de pouvoir des bildelberg et des
réunions secrètes où la presse n'est pas
conviée mais des journalistes sont au
contact avec une proximité vraiment trs
très pr du cercle ou de choses comme ça
le cercle c'est rien du tout le cercle
c'est non si vous voulez parler de
quelque chose on va commencer à parler
un petit peu trilatéral des choses comme
ça parce que le cercle c'est c'est quoi
moi je moi j'ai une position c'est un
rotar club pour retraité de luxe c'est
ça je sais pas j c'est c'est très
intéressant alors nous je suis ni
retraité et ni de luxe ni dans le cercle
c'est tout raté non mais j'approuve
j'approuve et j'applaudis les gens qui
se mett au pied du cercle pour voir à
peu près quelle tronne se balade là-bas
euh par contre il y a des plus gros
dossiers si vous voulez chercher les
gars envoyez-nous envoyez-nous des mails
on va vous dire où chercher hein on va
regarder le
euh donc j'en étais à les cercles du
pouvoir s'est passé est-ce que vous avez
des questions à nous poser vous non ce
que je voulais vous dire moi par rapport
au Cercle du pouvoir c'est que j'ai j'ai
et j'ai toujours eu une position assez
radicale c'est-à-dire que je fais partie
elle est contestable cette position mais
c'est la mienne euh moi je fais partie
des journalistes qui pensent que on ne
peut pas petit-déjeuner déjeuner dîner
avec des hommes politiques si ensuite on
veut faire des investigations euh dignes
de ce nom donc je suis très lointaine de
ce cercle làà ils le savent très bien je
ne les vois que pour les interview en
général sur des dossiers assez précis
euh donc donc ma ma position à moi elle
est claire il y a beaucoup de mes
confrères qui m'ont reproché qui me
reprochent et qui me disent beaucoup
plein qui disent mais si on veut avoir
des infos il faut aller boire des cafés
avec eux déjeuner dîner euh ah ça oui ça
ça peut aussi arriver mais non ils vont
pas jusqu'à me dire ce genre de chose
parce que moi j'en suis tellement loin
que il y a du chemin à faire franchement
et euh mais bon voilà ils me disent on
a' pas d'infos si si on n pas une
certaine proximité avec eux mais moi je
pense que les infos quand on les cherche
on les trouve et que les infos qu'il
nous donnent sont les informations
qu'ils veulent bien nous donner
connaissez le proverbe africain allez-y
quand tu te couches avec le diable le
lendemain matin quand qu tu te réveilles
tu sens encore le diable alors oui voilà
c'est ça mais mais même sans coucher je
pense qu'à un moment il faut se poser la
question de savoir pourquoi un homme
politique vous donne une information
parce qu'il disent oui mais c'est des
contacts on nous donne des informations
mais une information est jamais donnée
gratuitement est-ce que vous vous avez
des questions à nous poser
euh oui j'ai plein de questions à vous
poser parce que je pense
que vous avez
des des capteurs qu'on n
pas vous entendez vous sentez des choses
qu'on sent pas et que que je pense qu'à
un moment c'est c'est c'est bien qu'on
se parle c'est-à-dire
que chacun est dans son rôle je crois
qu'il faut pas jouer on est copain
copain on est potes c'est chacun est
dans son
rôle mais que c'est très important parce
que nous on a beau
être sur le boulot à fond avoir des gens
qui nous parlent de plus en plus on a
besoin de gens qui sentent aussi des
choses dans la société et puis qui et
puis qui sortent des choses aussi qui
voi qui sentent qui qui sortent des
infos qui peuvent nous échapper parce
qu'à un moment on a pas 12 cerveau
malheureusement ce serait bien ce serait
pratique mais on les a pas
et et que on a besoin de voilà on a
besoin de se parler je suis pas là par
hasard le message est passé en tous les
cas on a l'habitude de de demand nos
invités des conseils pour les jeunes
générations si vous aviez laisser une
bouteille à la mer pour les jeunes
générations ou laeriez quoi d'une façon
immortelle sur les réseaux immortel
personne ne l'a mais là pour l'instant
tout de suite maintenant qu'est-ce que
je leur
dirais je leur dirais que la vie
d'aujourd'hui elle est elle est elle est
vachement difficile parce que j'ai le
sentiment que déjà nous moi quand je su
j'ai eu 20 ans on nous disait wou c'est
la période du chômage c'est la crise
vous allez avoir du mal à trouver du
boulot euh j'ai j'ai vraiment pas que le
sentiment j'ai la certitude que c'est
beaucoup plus dur aujourd'hui encore et
donc on a tendance dans ces moments-là
euh à limiter ses ambitions et à se dire
je vais juste essayer d'avoir ça parce
que ça déjà avoir ça dans la société
c'est pas facile c'est compliqué juste
faire ma place et moi je leur dirais euh
non ayez de l'ambition euh sortez de
votre zone de confort allez-y euh prenez
des risques
euh il il y a ou l'eau tiède ou l'eau
froide ou l'eau chaude bah soyez pas
tiède quoi soyez froid ou chaud euh
distinguez-vous euh ne vous fondez pas
dans la masse je sais que la tentation
est grande parce que les risques sont
grands aujourd'hui dans la société mais
euh on ne voit que les gens qui se
distinguent et euh voilà assumez-vous
prenez des risques sortez de votre zone
de confort euh de toute façon vous vous
le ferez pas forcément après enfin on
peut toujours le faire après mais
euh voilà ne vous laissez surtout pas
couper vos ailes restreindre vos
ambitions vos envies vos rêves faites-le
sortez allez-y et puis si vous ratez
c'est pas
grave parce que on se souvient pas
forcément de ces échecs on se souvient
de ce qu'on a réussi puis que vous allez
réussir après
donc voilà faut faut faut surtout pas se
laisser impressionner par cette société
qui en ce moment est en train de réduire
les champise lu merci merci
[Musique]
sang je trempe la plume dans mon sang
laisse de la chair sur ma feuille tu
manges tu payes tu goûtes à l'IS pas en
tombant dans l'eau mais en y restant le
choix enterrer les morts ou soigner les
vivant Satan dirige le théâre Dieu écrit
ma pièce la gentillesse est un mauvais
MRE mais pas la sagesse je canalyse ton
stress profite de ton silence parce que
le rap c'est comme une à Polonie SAR à
balc ne parle pas d'économie sans parler
des colonies écoute leur paranoïa ma
schizophrénie au lieu de V ton cul tu
feris mieux de ton c tout ce qui te
divise nous réunit si tu me parlais de
cette maladie tuirais pas voir ton PS vu
qu'on partage le même pays à la vie à
l'amour à la mort de la vie pass-moi du
temps et je trouve un fling passe-moi un
fling et je braque une B passe-moi une
banque et je braque le monde la lumière
pas vos passe-moi une minute que je te
rendre Cha et je trouve un fling
passe-moiing et jeque oh